Two one and we're alive,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
uh,
or gentlemen to the ladies and gentlemen listening.
But Youtube,
unless you have some non-binary handle that you enjoy,
it's a new world.
Uh,
please,
please introduce yourself.
Sure.
So,
uh,
I'm Dr Mychart originally from Saint John's,
Newfoundland.
Uh,
now I'm residing in London,
Ontario and I'm a family doctor and I've been practicing cannabis medicine for
just over five years.
And
My name is Alex Berenson.
I used to be in New York Times reporter.
Uh,
then I became a spy novelist.
And most recently I wrote the book,
Tell Your children the truth about marijuana,
mental illness and violence,
which came out last month and,
uh,
has not endeared me to the cannabis advocacy community.
I'd say
have they attacked you mercilessly for this book?
Yes.
And that's,
and that's okay.
Um,
uh,
I've also heard from a lot of parents,
you know,
some users,
but parents who've told me,
uh,
that the book really encapsulates their,
their family's problems in the last couple of years.
Um,
I suspect my,
my real thoughts here before we even get started,
we're going to find that the truth is somewhere in the middle here.
Um,
I don't think marijuana is a hundred percent safe,
honestly for everybody.
I really don't,
I know too many people that have had experiences where they took too much,
particularly edibles and,
uh,
I don't,
I want to say I know anybody who had psychotic breaks,
but I know some people that freaked out for weeks,
you know,
in fact,
a,
we just had a,
a comedian here from Brazil.
Um,
a couple days ago,
Rafi Barstow's who said he took a couple of hits of a vape pen,
he was high for 14 days,
went to a psychiatrist and,
and he's a big guy.
He's like six foot five,
six,
you know,
and you know,
they told him to keep taking it cause you know,
he's like,
you're so big,
just keep smoking.
And so he,
he doesn't smoke.
So he just kept hitting this vape pen.
He said I was high for fucking two weeks.
You need to do it properly,
right.
Need to be held to the same standard as any other medicines.
So you need to identify that there's risks and there's benefits to it and some
people are definitely going to be more susceptible to those risks.
And we need to kind of tease out those people and make sure that those people,
you know,
don't put themselves at risk.
Yeah,
I think so as well.
And this is one of the reasons why I want to state this because I'm a well known
marijuana advocate,
but I,
I do believe,
I believe absolutely there are great benefits to it.
I think there's great benefits in terms of uh,
relieving pressure,
ocular pressure for people that have glaucoma,
people with aids who are on medication,
people with cancer that are going through chemotherapy find great benefit in
terms of helping them.
And then there's also some people with autism.
I know people that their children have autism and they give them small amounts
of edible marijuana and stops.
It's incredibly beneficial in the form of CBD for a lot of different ailments.
But I think with all things,
and this is a stance that I've kind of like really come to accept over the last
few years with all things that affect the mind,
they affect everyone slightly differently.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Alex,
he wanted to say something.
They're not full of force.
I suspect,
you know,
there were people who said,
don't go on with Joe.
He's just going to,
you know,
he's going to try to eat you alive and,
and especially there'll be,
it'll be two on one.
I told them the truth.
First of all,
I,
I'll go on with anybody and I am glad you had me on or you're having me on
because,
uh,
you know,
Bill Maher,
he won't have me on.
He's afraid to talk to me about this.
Why,
what did he say?
Well,
he,
you know,
he told the,
or his people told the Simon and Schuster PR people,
we just didn't want to have him on.
And a and NPR had a national NPR show,
had an interview scheduled with me,
an hour long segment and they canceled it.
They said,
they said,
we don't believe in the conclusions of the book.
Okay.
You don't believe in the conclusions in the book,
have me on ask me anything.
And that's why I'm so happy that you're not afraid to have me on that.
We can have a conversation that we can have a conversation come at me with any
question you want about the science.
Um,
I mean,
I'll say right off the top,
I don't think marijuana is medicine.
Uh,
it has a few,
uh,
medical uses,
that had been,
you know,
CBD has been shown to reduce seizures and kids.
That's great.
A THC has been,
uh,
shown to reduce the nausea associated with chemotherapy.
That's nice.
Uh,
but for the most part,
people use THC and cannabis has recreational and toxicants.
They used them to get high the same way they use alcohol the same way they use
other drugs.
And the sooner we,
we accept that reality,
the better off we'll all be.
That this is a drug and it has risks and benefits and the risks and benefits are
different than alcohol.
They're different than other drugs.
But I don't think if you look sort of on a population level basis,
they're less than alcohol.
I don't think you can even say that.
I don't,
I really strongly disagree with that.
And I mean,
you just have to look at the death rate,
right?
Uh,
you know,
more people die from alcohol and you know,
almost all drugs combined.
But when we're looking at cannabis,
there's zero deaths attributed to the use of cannabis itself.
Sure.
You could say,
you know,
someone could use cannabis and jump off a cliff or something like that,
but we're talking about the lethal dose.
You cannot die from cannabis.
And just based upon that alone,
it makes it much,
much safer than alcohol.
So the district,
could you say that that is the case?
So,
okay,
so that's a really good question.
Uh,
the normal number that's used for us deaths from alcohol,
it's about 90,000 now.
About 30 to 40,000 of those deaths are desk from the physical effects of
alcohol.
Right?
Essentially liver damage,
either chronic liver damage,
you get cirrhosis,
you die.
In some cases you can drink so much that you kill yourself in a night.
Uh,
so that's about 30 to 40,000 deaths.
The other deaths are generally associated alcohol,
meaning
somebody drank exactly violence,
suicide,
car accidents and the,
all those numbers are basically based on studies from the 90s and before where
you know,
people looked at traffic accidents and there were certain number of those
accidents where people had a blood alcohol content of higher than 0.1.
They said,
okay,
that's an alcohol associated death.
That's a fine way to count.
As far as I'm concerned,
nobody has ever done that count for cannabis.
And I can tell you based on the,
on the tox screens that I've seen from Colorado where people,
uh,
had cannabis in their blood and committed suicide,
people had cannabis in there are I should say THC and their blood and uh,
and got into a fatal confrontations with police officers.
If,
if,
and when we do this number for cannabis,
which we need to do as soon as possible,
the number's going to be a lot higher than zero.
I suspect it will be in the 10 to 20,000 range.
We won't know till we actually do it.
Okay,
well let's,
let's eliminate,
let's go even over the alcohol.
Let's eliminate all things like violence and what's eliminate suicide.
And let's assume those people would have committed violence and committed
suicide.
Without it.
You're still looking at a giant number of people who drink themselves to death.
Thousands and thousands and thousands of people every year versus zero with
marijuana.
And you're aware,
I'm sure that correlation does not equal causation and that,
especially in a place like Colorado where you're dealing with cannabis,
something that stays in the system for many,
many weeks.
If you're testing people and they test positive for marijuana and they wind up
committing suicide or they wind up committing violence,
they don't even necessarily have to have been under the influence of it.
Well,
as you know,
there's w when you test the blood,
you can test the both the active metabolite and the inactive metabolite of THC.
So,
so the test,
when you do a blood test on somebody who's,
you know,
has committed suicide,
it's sophisticated enough to tease that out.
Um,
so there's a lot of people who have the active metabolite in their blood.
I agree.
Alcoholics,
they physically toxic substance.
Cannabis is a neurotoxin for a lot of people.
But in addition to,
you know,
the death,
there's also just the morbidity that's associated with alcohol.
I mean,
it ruins people's lives.
That ruins marriages.
Uh,
it leads to weight gain.
It leads to a lot of metabolic disturbances.
Thank you can say that for some people with marijuana too,
I think you could say some people,
especially weight gain,
that some people smoke a lot of pot and they get lazy and they started eating
Cheetos all day.
And,
and you could also say that with some people,
you know,
the wakened bakers that,
seem to be wasting their lives away.
And that's like the stereotypical negative con,
you know,
when you were talking about a negative description of a marijuana user,
it's the waking Baker.
At first it was high all the time.
You could absolutely said that could really ruin relationships.
You could absolutely say that it would ruin your job.
You could.
But again too,
you know,
we're using the term marijuana and really we should be using THC or high THC
when we're saying that because you know,
people who use a high CBD every day as we know are most people listen,
this is pure CBD,
is non psychoactive,
not get you high,
super beneficial.
That can be extremely beneficial for you know,
a variety of different disorders that people have.
So,
you know,
we really need to be careful about using canvas versus using,
THC because it's really the THC that can do that.
And to your point,
you know,
but you know,
you say like THC can cause the munchies and of course that's,
you know,
not good for someone who doesn't want to gain weight and just,
so people know the,
the way that it does do that is when she see attached to the CB one receptor,
you had an increase in a hormone called Ghrelin and Ghrelin can actually induce
hunger.
And that's why people get get the munchies.
But you know,
that is not necessarily a bad thing if you're someone who has cancer or if you
or someone you know,
who,
who's wasting away from,
from,
from a terrible illness,
you know,
sometimes,
having,
uh,
having the munchies is,
is definitely a good thing.
Um,
and I know,
you know,
a lot of people have said to me,
it's not available so you should probably not talk about as much,
but there is another cannabinoid called THCV.
So you know,
there's,
there's over a hundred cannabinoids in cannabis cheat seeing CD are only two of
them.
You know,
those are the main ones that people know about.
So THCV has been shown to actually reduce appetite.
So if we can get that out there in the market,
you know,
like we have with,
with CBD,
then we can almost feel eliminate or potentially,
you know,
substantially reduced the problem that people have with,
with,
uh,
with THC by using it,
with THCV darker.
And I have a question for you.
When people come into your practice,
did they,
do they want high CBD products or did they want to get intoxicated?
And No,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Sure.
Of course.
Yeah.
So it's like if they don't need to go to him to get intoxicated.
So people,
so you're seeing a population that is genuinely interested in the health
benefits?
Absolutely,
because I mean if enemies,
I'm glad that that,
uh,
that's legalized in Canada because it does make my job a little bit easier
because be like basically everyone who is coming to me now,
I know that they want to use it medically because if they want to use it
recreationally,
I mean they just go to the store,
right.
Cause it's kind of a pain to,
you know,
get in to see me come in and have the discussion,
all that type of stuff.
So you know,
the people who see me now,
um,
you know,
they're all using it medically.
Um,
and then,
you know,
to answer your question though,
Alex,
almost all my patients,
as soon as they come in,
they say I don't want to get high.
I don't want to get high.
Like that's almost what everyone says.
So,
you know,
I think the word is out there that uh,
CBD is non psychoactive and it doesn't get you high.
And I think that a lot of people are really interested in that compound and you
know,
if,
if the people didn't have the success that they've had over the past few years,
you know,
it wouldn't be as popular as it is.
So,
you know,
I think that,
um,
you know,
we do need to look at the scientific evidence,
but we do need to listen to others in the anecdotal evidence is,
you know,
something that,
that,
that we should consider because it is so strong.
Alex,
let me ask you this,
why don't you consider it medicine when it has proven medical benefits?
It obviously can be medicine for these narrow things that FDA has approved
it for.
But as you know,
I'm sure when people talk about it as Madison,
when the,
the,
the ballot initiatives that have gotten it approved as a medicine have really
essentially deceive voters about the process.
Right?
So you go to a,
you go to a pot doctor,
you get an authorization.
That authorization essentially enables you to buy as much cannabis as you want
for the next year.
Most of the time,
in reality,
these doctors are not giving you a real medical examination.
They're saying to you,
Hey,
do you have pain?
Do you have anxiety?
Here's your authorization.
I don't think you should speak for every single doctor loan or we don't do that.
Uh,
at my clinic.
And I know that,
you know,
a lot of the clinics in Canada anyway,
uh,
we definitely do not do that.
And,
uh,
you know,
we provide a lot of education at my clinic and there's other clinics in Canada.
The also
sure education and,
and I,
and I imagine there's a spectrum,
but in the US,
this was a [inaudible] and I spoke to advocates from our book.
I spoke to Rob Kampia,
who,
you know,
who ran the marijuana policy project for a long time,
um,
for the book.
And He,
and he acknowledged,
you know,
the advocates knew that this was a backdoor route to legalization in the yoga.
I used to joke around about it.
Yeah.
My doctor said,
uh,
why do you do pot?
I said,
I'd get headaches.
He said,
when do you get headaches?
I said,
whenever I think about the fact that pot's illegal when wrote me a prescription.
I mean,
let's be honest about it.
I'm not,
look,
I say in the book at the end,
I don't think this should be,
this substance should be legal.
I have favorite decriminalization.
We're sort of jumping ahead here,
but if it's gonna be legal,
I'd rather have it be legal for recreational use.
I'd rather that we don't pretend that THC high cannabis is a medicine and I'd
rather separate out.
Yeah,
but why are you saying don't pretend?
Because there's many medicines that have horrific side effects.
The medicine,
THC in regards to children's autism is pretty significant and well documented.
The epilepsy,
autism,
those are two huge things that happen with children that they've been shown to
severely mitigate with with edible marijuana.
So I have to push back on you a little bit.
CBD has been shown to reduce seizures in children with epilepsy.
It's,
it's okay.
It's approved for me.
Be Anecdotal,
but I have a good friend who has a child who he uses it on it and he showed you
mean it's been a game change,
right?
Yeah.
I mean I let just let me interrupt for sex.
Like I had a patient four or five years ago and uh,
she was 20 years old.
She couldn't drive a car because she had seizures.
Right.
So you can imagine being 20 years old,
not being able to drive a car,
all your friends are driving around.
So she uses a little bit of CBD,
not even every day.
She's never had a seizure since.
And now she's able to drive her car.
But this is,
we're talking about CBD,
he's talking about THC.
So you're talking about,
you're talking about a case.
Okay.
And,
and I'm not saying that your friend's situation didn't happen.
I'm not saying it's not real.
What I'm saying is that the reason we have clinical trials is because science,
the way you know whether a medicine works or not,
whether a chemical compound works,
whatever that company is,
the best way to know is you give it to two groups of you give,
you give the real medicine to one group of people and you give a placebo to the
other group and you see the changes in those two groups over time and you find
out whether you're not,
your theory about whether this works on a population level basis is real or not.
That's how that is at the core of medical science.
And we've basically thrown that rule out for THC.
Well that's not entirely correct.
You do know that there's were studies that were run during the Nixon
administration that showed the efficacy of marijuana and the safety of it,
and those were all squashed.
And you also,
I'm sure you know like when we're talking about marijuana,
you talking about something that's federally illegal,
it's not something that's ego that's easy to run these FDA studies on.
Yes,
and I do.
And I said at the end of the book,
I think we should drop that.
I think anybody who's got a legitimate interest in researching either THC or
cannabis or any of the compounds for a,
for a medical condition,
let them run phase one,
phase two,
phase three,
trust.
Let's see if this,
if this,
if this plant is good for these things,
I think that's a great idea.
But still,
why are you saying that you don't think it is medicine when all these people
find benefit in it?
So,
so do you think they're getting it from just the CBD,
the minimal amount of CBD and marijuana?
No,
I think that,
again,
there,
there's been a lot of research done on THC and cannabis to see whether or not
those,
whether THC is a compound in weather,
smoke,
cannabis can treat these conditions.
And for the most part,
the studies have been negative.
The,
again,
there's negative in what way?
Meaning they haven't shown any actual,
uh,
like,
can you stay cite these studies there?
I mentioned that in my book.
Okay,
well what,
what were the conclusions of these studies?
When you're saying that they're not positive,
that they,
again,
that they didn't work,
that the drug didn't work on what?
On cancer,
on Alzheimer's disease,
on irritable bowel syndrome,
on.
So Alex to mean,
you know,
you're throwing a few different things out there and you know,
I appreciate the fact that we can't be going around.
You're saying things like,
you know,
cannabis cures cancer,
right?
But you know,
I,
uh,
you know,
and I've done videos on this even like recently stating that,
but if you look at the research,
I mean specifically if you look at specific cancers,
uh,
there are studies that have shown that THC and CBD can help.
Like it's safe.
We're talking about breast cancer.
And I did a video on this recently.
You know,
if you are her two positive and use cheats seeing CBD,
it came in fact,
uh,
reduce tumor size and it can reduce tumor growth.
Now if you have,
what does,
I'm sorry,
can I interrupt you?
What does that mean?
What does this subset of of breast cancer,
right?
So,
um,
there's,
there's different types of breast cancer and that's just one subset of,
of breast cancer.
So there are other breast cancers which do not express cannabinoid receptors.
And you know,
I've seen a one study,
at least,
again,
it's only one study that show that when they gave cheat seat and that animal
model and actually cause a proliferation of,
of tumors,
so it worse than them.
So,
you know,
I do agree with you Alex,
and the fact that,
you know,
we have to be careful about using terms like that,
but that just doesn't mean that we can't say that cannabis has no good for
cancer at all.
And I mean,
even in the National Academies of Science and Engineering Report,
you know,
they said that cancer was,
was great for chemotherapy induced nausea and vomiting.
Right.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's definitely a really good,
um,
you know,
medicine for,
a lot of different things.
And when we're talking about cheat,
see,
you know,
I,
uh,
I said earlier,
of course,
and we need to be careful about,
about THC,
but it definitely is still a medicine.
And you know,
to your point with regards to,
um,
you know,
not being a medicine say for something like Ptsd,
I come from it from a clinician's point of view,
so I'm not a researcher,
so I need to make sure that my patients are getting better.
It's very frustrating for me just to say to someone,
oh,
there's nothing I can do for you.
There's nothing I can do for it,
you know,
so,
and I understand that,
you know,
doing something sometimes a is not going to be beneficial just because you're
doing something,
you have to do something that actually works.
But,
you know,
we do have epidemiological studies and we have,
uh,
other studies have shown that,
um,
you know,
when patients are given a cannabis,
it can reduce their symptoms of PTSD.
There's also another study,
you know,
I don't use this drug too often,
call it called Nabilone.
So nabilone is just pure THC.
Nabilone was shown to reduce nightmares and people who have PTSD.
So,
you know,
it's just saying,
just so,
just because THC is psychoactive doesn't mean that it's not a medicine.
And just to keep on the topic of,
of PTSD.
Um,
in addition to that,
we've identified mechanisms of action.
Um,
I know there's one study,
I think Matt Hill was on the,
uhW,
was one of the authors of that study and he noticed that and people who have
PTSD,
there's an over 50% decrease in,
uh,
in levels of [inaudible].
So a nature on the naturally occurring,
which is,
which is a naturally occurring in the canal when it correct.
Um,
so you can get that through,
through exercise,
which is one excellent way to do it.
And you know,
and that's part of the,
uh,
the high that,
that you get after you exercise.
But the other way that you can get it is by using cannabis.
So when,
when she,
she attaches to those CB one receptors,
you can get a release of an anti mind and,
uh,
Kinda dial can actually increase in antibiotic by another mechanism of action as
well.
So,
you know,
there's different ways where we can,
raise a level of,
of deficiency.
So,
you know,
to me as a clinician,
if I have someone who is not doing very well,
you know,
they've been on a bunch of different medications,
I've identified that they have PTSD,
we have mechanisms of action,
we have studies.
And then again too,
you know,
don't discount my clinical experience.
Right.
I've been,
uh,
working for over five years,
you know,
just with,
uh,
just with cannabis.
I mean,
I do other medicines,
I use prescribed other medicines as well,
but I've been doing medicine for over five years and you know,
there's a lot that,
that I've learned,
right?
So as much as I've learned,
you know,
through reading studies,
um,
and,
and through going to conferences and things like that,
you know,
for sure that the best resource as a clinician is to learn from your patients
and to hear what your patients tell me.
And you know,
the,
the things that my patients tell me is that THC is really effective for the
sleep at night.
And a lot of my patients,
especially my veteran patients,
had done really,
really well with that.
And just,
just one further point too,
you know,
there was a,
I know it was,
it was in 2015 I believe it was.
There was a Meta analysis done.
I can pull it up if we need to,
that indicated that,
um,
you know,
a lot of medicines that are being used now for PTSD or just simply ineffective.
And the other thing too is that there's never been a medicine made specifically
for PTSD.
So all the medicines that people are using or for anxiety or there for
depression or the for insomnia there,
Arthur for something else,
you know,
but when we look at a study that says people with PTSD have a lower level of
[inaudible],
and then if you can increase that a level of Nando mind,
you know,
that's a good way to treat someone.
It doesn't matter whether it's a vitamin,
whether it's a hormone,
if belongs as you are correcting a deficiency,
you're generally going to get excellent clinical results.